the University of Goma has seen better
days broken glass is a reminder of
clashes with the authorities it's no
wonder that the youth movement la lucha
was born here away from the public gaze
law graduate and la lucia member juven
combee agrees to meet us in a hotel he
remembers the beginning of the group's
troubles with authorities malloy teach
you I'm puppy we wrote a message on a
flyer Africa has such in such a
percentage of water dr congo has such a
percentage of water who can help Africa
survive de la fricassee of you Oh Deus
here in go mom we don't have running
water that evening police and the area
wanted to know who was giving out the
flyers and who had made them when I told
them that I had made the Flyers your
booty like they arrested US woman get
this inside when I the oquirrh moved out
it they were very brutal up and throw us
into a pickup truck love me though that
was the first time they were arrested of
what the bad roads the daily walks to
fetch water and the general hardship of
life in Goma are what motivated the
young activists to call for change they
took it upon themselves to educate the
people around them and prepare them for
elections lose a Yolanda cuts we go out
into the neighborhoods onto the streets
and discuss with the people people
consider to me from lower classes the
bus class we asked them whether they
have any problems and they tell us yes
we do have problems we don't have proper
roads we don't have this we don't have
that you own the monarchy we then asked
them to write down their problems sir
citizen and when a political candidate
comes to ask those very questions yo
repose ilium kitchen the fight for
change will not stop at these elections
says combi it's an ongoing struggle
when he was imprisoned his sister also
decided to join the movement like her
brother she believes that she has to
sacrifice her quiet life for her ideals
guy ever dude when there were arrests or
when we organized activities and were
badly beaten we came home injured and
our families often didn't know how to
help have a bond zeki a deux fois the
authorities try to discourage us and
sometimes it reaches a point when it's
really hard to continue our fight
continued and i'll eat again someone
played a mainly the activists have made
their voices heard and maybe that's what
it will take to improve things for the
people of eastern DRC